Yesterday morning we discussed three
instances
when a salah is exempt, an optional
prayer, so a prayer that is not an
obligatory prayer, is exempt
from the prohibited times of salah.
So we mentioned three
types of optional prayer
that are exempt
from the prohibited times of salah. So
it's prohibited to pray after Fajr until
the sun rises high. It's prohibited to
pray about 15-20 minutes before Dhuhr.
It's prohibited to pray about 15-20
minutes
before Maghrib, and some scholars say
after Asr entirely until Maghrib. And so
what are those three instances? We said
Three.
Those
optional prayers which are connected to
a specific time
or place
or occasion
or event.
Right?
And the author gives us a first example
of
an optional prayer that is connected
or specified
tied to a time. And that first example
he gives us is making optional prayer in
sets of two before
Jumu', before the khutbah begins.
So
usually the khutbah is done after the
adhan of Dhuhr.
And a person waits
meaning after the adhan of Dhuhr,
meaning after the time of Dhuhr is in.
Is it permissible to do Jumu' before
the time of Dhuhr? Yes, it is. But
usually it is done after the time of
Dhuhr is in cuz Jumu' is not a
supplement for Dhuhr. They are not
interchangeable.
And
[Arabic recitation]
Dhuhr to come in, they're waiting for
the Imam to go on the mimbar
the sun will be at that point
at its highest point in the sky and at
that time it's prohibited to pray.
Correct?
Except during Jumu'.
When a person is awaiting the Imam to
rise on the mimbar, the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam encouraged
that a person continue to make optional
prayer in sets of two until the Imam
rises onto the minbar.
And at this point, salah, optional
prayer, then stops.
[Silence]
The author makes a very interesting
observation here.
He says the prophet
was selling encourages the person who is
awaiting the khutbah of Jumu' to
continue to make optional prayer in sets
of two until the Imam
emerges and climbs onto the minbar.
So, the prophet
was selling made the time
when a person stops praying optional
prayer
when the sun reaches its zenith or when
the Imam emerges.
When the Imam rises on the minbar. So,
on a regular day,
Saturday through Thursday and Friday for
anyone who's not going to Jumu',
the time when a person is prohibited
from prayer
is when the sun is at its highest point
at the exact center in the sky
at its zenith.
However, for a person who is making
Jumu' and awaiting Jumu' to begin,
that doesn't apply to them.
When is it prohibited for him to pray?
When the Imam rises onto the mimbar.
And for this reason, a number of the
salaf Salaf here doesn't mean Salafi.
Salaf here means the companions, the
tabi'in, tabi'i tabi'in.
So,
a number of the companions and the most
early of scholars have noted that the
time
when prayer is prohibited for those
attending Jumu' is when the Imam rises
onto the mimbar.
And the point when speaking is
prohibited is when the Imam begins to
speak.
I'll repeat that there.
For a person who's attending Jumu',
the point when salah becomes
prohibited
is when the Imam rises onto the mimbar.
Now, there's no more salah. For persons
in salah, they finish their prayer
quickly and they await the Imam's
khutbah.
So, when the prayer stops is when the
Imam rises on the mimbar. When speaking
becomes prohibited is when the Imam
begins his khutbah.
Not necessarily when the adhan is being
called.
This is another misconception and that
is that the companions radiyallahu anhum
used to speak to one another while the
adhan was being made for Jumu'.
When would they when the when would
work speaking become prohibited?
When the Imam begins the khutbah. That's
when speaking is prohibited.
So, insat, which is silence, that begins
at the point that the Imam begins
speaking.
And salah,
its prohibition begins when the Imam
rises onto the mimbar.
Right?
And for everyone else,
all of the rest of the Muslimeen
who are not attending Jumu',
they
are to stop making prayer when the sun
reaches its zenith, just any other
day.
So, this optional prayer is connected to
a time, which is the time of Jumu'
specifically, the attendance of Jumu'.
That exempts a person from the the
aforementioned prohibition.
And we will continue to mention other
examples of this, inshallah ta'ala,
in the coming days.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]